[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en mettant les pieds pour la première
fois dans le ferry de mombasa je me suis
dit en bon blanc un peu qu'on a le plus
grand bac d'afrique le plus peuplé va y
avoir du sport du chahut des coups de
gueule des chansons des nains aux fesses
des vendeurs à la sauvette des
pickpockets
non mon garçon ici c'est l'afrique de
l'est l'afrique du fleix
et de cantat soir
le pays soit y lit de sahil la côte en
arabe afrik com et i7 core en élégance
massaï est réservé aux bouslim
carbonneau
[Musique]
un bras de mer qui permet aux cargos au
porte conteneurs l'entrée du seul port
du kenya mais un bras de mer qui sépare
la ville il de mon bassin de toute la
côte sud du pays jusqu'à la tanzanie pas
de pont jamais ou alors par un détour de
20 kilomètres par les embouteillages
bref c'est le bac
ou rien
[Musique]
côte sud c'est la banlieue interminable
aligné sur la route où s'agglutinent les
petites gens venus de la campagne
pas un sou en poche mais des idées de
business plein la tête
marie marchand de légumes a trouvé sa
niche marketing
[Musique]
avant les affaires marchaient bien nous
avions une grande boutique
et puis tout le monde s'est mis à faire
la même chose alors on a ouvert un
restaurant à vendre des légumes seul ce
n'était plus rentable alors mari a
trouvé la parade
une fille vendeuse qui la remplace dès
qu'il s'absente et un mario fourneaux
dans son café restaurant mais dont elle
est le fournisseur exclusif en fruits et
légumes
en effet c'est un bon client mais
attention il faut qu'il paie ce nom la
fois d'après rien je livre pas voilà
comment de boutiques hier deux faubourgs
mari s'est donc faite semi grossiste bnf
assuré mais le grand marché central
il est de l'autre côté à mombasa de
l'autre côté du ferry côte sud toujours
un peu à l'écart de la route nationale
money a opté lui pour la filière noix de
coco
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
chômeur d'une plantation de thé en
faillite il ne reste plus à moi ni qu'un
acres de terrain planté d'une poignée
d'arbres il doit se gagner une vie de ça
un jour avant d'avoir un vélo j'ai pris
un mini bus jusqu'au ferry et là j'ai
trouvé quelqu'un qui avait un vélo je
lui confirme les noix de coco on s'est
mis d'accord pour le prix je les payais
en lui disant où il devait laisser ma
marchandise
j'ai laissé partir je suis allé jusqu'au
centre ville
mais il n'est jamais venu un autre
rendez vous j'ai attendu attendu jusqu'à
perdre espoir
alors j'ai décidé qu'il valait mieux que
je m'achète au burlesque
les gens de la ville de mombasa de
l'autre côté commence à avoir soif vers
11 heures du matin quand le soleil tape
un gosier sec les bons payeurs
après c'est trop tard alors vite au bac
pour moi ni ses 10 km contre la montre
marie elle n'a qu'à rattraper un minibus
l'avantagent d'habiter au bord de la
nationale
la rupture aux caraïbes
[Musique]
hélas
tous
[Musique]
la route du ferry c'est une artère où
débouche mille sentiers chemins ruelle
peuplée d'un patient al'approche de
l'embarcadère l'artère est sous pression
[Musique]
cannes
tu arrives sur la route principale qui
va opérer
il ya beaucoup de circulation il faut
être très doué avec un vélo charge au
col fine lame est ce qu'elle pense à toi
tu roules est une tare il un 4/4 par
derrière qui te fait une queue de
poisson requip il si ton vélo est pas un
état je te crache dessus
[Musique]
autour de moi ni le vendeur de noix de
coco de marie la maraîchère ils sont
tous là ceux des faubourgs
il ya monsieur joseph au camp guy
menuisier partie dénicher un lot de
blanche il y à dalton qui va tenter sa
chance comme débardeur sur les docks
jefferson et chris malina debout depuis
5 e pour rejoindre leur collège il ya
mademoiselle bahati ça veut dire chance
qui va apprendre la coiffure dans un
salon du centre ville il y à des
employés de bureau des professeurs des
guides cents clients
il y à des manoeuvres mis leurs amis
leurs seins épaules nues crâne prêt à
tout supporter pour gagner leur vie d'un
jouet jusqu'au bac du soir et avant
celui du lendemain
salut déjà de retour aux heures de
pointe c'est trois ferries à la fois
qu'ils sont en rotation pour absorber le
flux des gens du sud passant vers
mombasa une demi-heure d'attentes
parfois une heure et toujours pas une
bousculade
pas un mot de trop
[Musique]
mais pital est aux yeux papa
mais la f1 sur le ferry c'est comme si
on coupait mon bassin en 2 ça
reviendrait à paralyser toute la ville a
plu à vélo plus onirique imagine tous
ces gens qui viennent de loin du sud des
faubourgs situe leur enlève le ferry
c'est comme si la moitié de la ville
s'est échoué
[Musique]
qui derrière le juteux monopole de la
kenyane ferry services limited une mafia
locale et les collisions et les hommes à
la mer à on allez rigoler sur le nombre
de brassières iso 9000 combien d'affairé
cap tony stanley déception sur toute la
ligne
nous voilà devant le plus gros ferries
d'afrique aux mains du service public
gratuit pour les piétons
quelques shillings pour les véhicules
pas le moindre petit naufrage ni même un
pépin grave depuis 40 ans des équipages
tous diplômés qui alterne toutes les
huit heures la suède quoi seize mille
personnes par jour 64 millions de
passagers transportés 365 jours par an
24 heures sur 24 de la côte sud à la
ville de la ville à la côte sud et
stanley intègre en plus les passagers
perdre leur calme c'est jamais sans
raison par exemple c'est qu'il n'y a pas
ces ferries qui tourne et trop de monde
a embarqué et pour dire la vérité
nos passagers sont des gens bien et si
ça dégénère c'est généralement de notre
faute
bon ça c'est quelque chose qu'on n'aime
pas trop dire mais les problèmes
ils viennent souvent nu
quand on prend le ferry c'est un autre
monde
je peux croiser quelqu'un que je connais
bien et alors on se regarde dans les
yeux mais on ne se dit rien parce que ni
lui ni moi on ne se sait pas où on va on
va avoir de la chance
mata tout en langue swahili signifie ça
vaut 3 pour dire ça vaut 3 chez ligne la
course si tu montes dans mon mini bus
mais des sites web parce qu'il ya de
monde derrière
suffit pas de passer le bac mari pour
rejoindre le marché de l'autre côté de
la ville il faut encore attrapez un
matin tôt
et ça vaut plus 3 chez ligne depuis
longtemps on serait plutôt à 70 50
centimes d'euro et s'aggrave tous les
jours mais voilà pourquoi le chou
augmente dans les faubourgs
[Musique]
ouais
hier
vive marine acheter au bon prix les
meilleurs produits qu'ils tiendront un
jour ou deux sur ton et al allez mari
rentre chez toi et rejoint son mari de
l'autre côté du ferry juste le temps
d'affréter des porteurs qui livreront
des achats le chef des porteurs
s'appelle justice un bon présage
sûrement vite
oui nous étancher la soif de ces bonnes
gens de la ville avant que ne vienne
l'heure du thé au gingembre du café à la
cardamome 60 centimes d'euro la noix x
50 moins deux fois 40 centimes de
ferries si tu ne crève pas un pneu au
retour à jour n'est fait
alors moi ouais ouais
si vous montez un jour sur le ferry de
mombasa on vous racontera sûrement
l'histoire de korean air
cette blanche venue de suisse dont la
vie a basculé en cinq minutes le temps
d'une traversée
pas la peine de lire les 3 193 pages de
son roman au corry n'a cru bon tout
déballé de son aventure non la première
page suffit
après une longue marche le ferry est
enfin en vue entre les voitures qui
attendent se tiennent des centaines de
personnes avec des cartons les chariots
et des poulets toutes veulent embarquer
sur le ferry à double pont finalement
nous parvenons à monter nous aussi à
bord où se produit un événement inouï
[Musique]
marco me dit corinne regarde là bas
c'est un masaï
je demande où ça et je me tourne dans la
direction qu'il m'indique je suis frappé
comme si j'avais reçu la flou dans un
homme très grand et très beau à la peau
foncée est assis sur le garde-corps dans
une position décontracté et nous fixe de
ses yeux sombres pour le seul blanc au
milieu de cette crue
je pense mon dieu qu'il est beau je n'ai
jamais vu personne de semblable je ne
peux plus détourner le regard
assis devant le soleil couchant il
ressemble un jeune dieu dans cinq
minutes
le ferry accostera et tous se mettront à
courir à prendre l'assaut l'écart et à
se disperser à tout vent je ne
reviendrai plus jamais cette arme
baumann
6 rassurez vous corinne retrouvera son
mass eye elle quittera tout marco la
suisse aura beaucoup d'emmerdements
sentimentale ou sexuelle
tout cela à cause d'une traversée de
cinq minutes sur le ferry dont bas ça ne
rigolait pas interrogez vos amis combien
de premiers baisers au passage d'un bac
combien de pour toujours de plus jamais
ça essayez vous même nul n'est à l'abri
des sortilèges du passeur
[Musique]